WELCOME BACK TO OUR LAST
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION HEARING THE LAST
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING ALL STATE
THAT AGAIN.
THE QUIVER ROLL CALL THE CELL
WAS QUORUM PLEASE.
COOPER HERE TO LACKEY.
NAZARIAN PRESENT WICKS.
HERE.
WE HAVE THIRTY ITEMS ON THE BOAT
ONLY CALENDAR -- ISSUES ONE
THROUGH NINE ELEVEN TO SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN THROUGH. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY THREE THIRTY
FIVE AND THIRTY SEVEN IS OUR
MOTION.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY.
NAZARIAN.
WICKS [inaudible]
ISSUE.
TEN OUR MOTION TO IN ORDER TO
ISSUE TEN TWENTY TEN TWENTY TO
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY THIRTY ONE
AND THIRTY SIX IS OUR MOTION.
ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI TO
LACKEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
WICKS.
ISSUE EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE AND
THIRTY TWO THE MOTION.
ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI
LACKEY NO.
NAZARIAN.
WICKS HI.
IN THIS ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT
MOTION PLEASE [inaudible]
REPUBLIC.
COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
WICKS.
OKAY NEXT WE HAVE TWO ITEMS TO
BE HEARD THE FIRST IS FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD -- YEAH I. T. C. I'M
SORRY.
THE THIRTY EIGHT YEAH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
PLEASE BE ON SORRY [inaudible]
I GOT.
SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE
ASSEMBLY PLAN INCLUDE EXPAND THE
CREDIT TO INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS.
ITN.
WE'VE INCLUDED THE AYE TEENS ARE
PLAN LAST YEAR AND WANT TO
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
INCLUDING THIS GROUP IN
EXPANSION.
INCLUDES A MORE MODEST FUNDING
PLAN FOR THE GOVERNOR BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THE ADDING THE AYE
TIENES WOULD BE PRIORITY BEFORE
EXPANDING THE CREDIT FOR FOR
THEIR SPEND CREDIT.
AUGMENTS FUNDING UP FOR OUR
REGION FREE TAX PREPARATION BY
FIVE MILLION FOR A TOTAL OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
WE CONTINUE SUPPORT ADVANCE
PAYMENT THE REQUIRE SOME
INFORMATION FROM THE F. T.
BEFORE BEFORE THIS PROGRAM -- SO
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT
THE I. T. C. AS OUTLINED IN THE
AGENDA THEIR MOTION.
ALSO GONNA ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI Q. [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
WICKS.
CAN THIS WILL THIS NUMBER TO
CANNABIS TAX.
ONE THANKS.
TO THE ASSEMBLY PLAN REAPER TIES
A PROGRAMS WITH A CANNABIS TAX.
ONE WE GIVE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OF THE FUN IS CONTAINS
THE APPROPRIATED HOWEVER
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS ROOM FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
PRIORITIES HE MADE A
CONSULTATION THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THESE REASONS THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
PROVIDING DIRECTION OF PARTIES
THE CANVAS TAX ONE AS OUTLINED
ON THE AGENDA.
I NOTE THERE WAS NO MISSION ON
THE PRINT AGENDA THAT LEFT OUT
THE RECOMMENDATION THE TEN
MILLION TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
STATE WHAT ENFORCEMENT.
AGAINST UNLICENSED CANNABIS
OPERATORS WITH AN EMPHASIS ON A
LICENSE CANNABIS RETAIL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT CHANGE IS THE FIXED ONLINE
FOR RECOMMENDATION INCLUDES A
TEN MILLION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S YEAH I HAVE A
SELECTION.
OF THIS PROPOSAL RE APPROPRIATES
TEN MILLION THAT WAS NOT SPENT
LAST YEAR FROM THE ACT THE
PROGRAM.
IS THIS IN ADDITION TO THE FIFTY
MILLION THAT WAS PROPOSED MAY
REVISE.
THANK COUNT APARTMENT FINANCE
THAT YES THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WAS A PART OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
DEAL THAT WENT TO EQUITY
PROGRAMS IT'S TAKEN SOME TIME.
TO GET THAT MONEY OUT SO -- WE
NEED TO BE APPROPRIATE THE FUNDS.
SO SO IT IS IN ADDITION TO THE
FIFTY MILLION IT WAS SUPPOSED
YEAH IT WAS IT WAS ORIGINALLY
APPROPRIATED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BUDGET BACK SO IT IS IN
ADDITION.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
JUST ONE MONTH MOMENT HAD JUST
SAID JUST A COMMENT ON THE
ACTION HERE WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THE INITIATIVE -- SPECIFIED THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ABLE TO
MAKE THE DETERMINATION ON HOW
THE FUNDS.
ARE ALLOCATED SO.
WE WILL CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION
OKAY LOOK FORWARD TO IT WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMON THIS ITEM.
EMOTION IS BIG.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AM I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND
STAFF FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF INDUSTRY.
WITH THE PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE
STATE AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACCOUNT WERE PARTICULARLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR RECOMMENDATION
TO DIRECT AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION TO ENFORCE AGAINST
UNLICENSED RETAIL ACTIVITY.
AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
HEARING OUR CONCERNS.
THE TEN MILLION COULD BE USED TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS UNDER THE BCC.
POTENTIALLY OR WITH OVERSIGHT --
WHICH HAS OVERSIGHT OVER
CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION TESTING IN
RETAIL.
UNDER THE CURRENT STRUCTURE THE
BCC HAS LIMITED ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY AGAINST UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY AND INSTEAD MUST RELY
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
INVESTIGATION.
MAKING ENFORCEMENT A LONG AND
INEFFECTUAL PROCESS IN FACT
ACCORDING TO OUR RESEARCH THE
STATE HAS TAKEN FEWER THAN FORTY
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AGAINST
ILLICIT CANNABIS BUSINESSES
SINCE THE PROGRAM TOOK AFFECT IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ADDITIONALLY
CCA'S STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE COMPETITIVE
LOCAL GRANT PROGRAM TO COMBAT
ILLEGAL CANNABIS CULIVATION IN
SALES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WITH RESPECT TO THE LOCAL GRANT
PROGRAM WE FOR THE REQUESTED ANY
IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE INCLUDE A
LOCAL MATCH REQUIREMENT TO
QUALIFY FOR THESE FUNDS.
MANY JURISDICTIONS ARE THE
LEADING HYPE LEVYING HIGH TAXES
AND FEES ON THE COMPLAINT
INDUSTRY TO BOLSTER ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS.
AND YET LITTLE ENFORCEMENT HAS
OCCURRED.
THE STATE AS WELL AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUST HAVE SOME SKIN
IN THE GAME IF WE ARE TO COMBAT
THE ILLICIT MARKET AND ACHIEVE
THE GOALS EXPRESSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THEY ENACTED
THEM A CURSE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO SUPPORT A THRIVING
LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY WHILE
ENHANCING PUBLIC AND CONSUMER.
SAFETY THANK YOU THANK YOU ON
THINKING MISTAKEN FOR BEING
INVOLVED THE PROCESS.
TO GOOD AFTERNOON MR SURE KATHY
VAN AUSTIN MBM STRATEGY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF SAM G. KLAY BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO SAY HELP HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE.
OF FOR THE APPROPRIATION FOR TEN
MILLION.
FOR ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S WE'VE SEEN FIRST HAND --
THE IMPACTS AND DAVID.
BRINKLEY THE DESPERATE NEED FOR
FOR LOOK HORSEMEN SO WE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
THANK YOU.
FOR HI IT IS THE LEGACY OF KINGS
ON BEHALF OF EAST WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF ADDITIONAL MONEY
FORM FORSMAN ESPECIALLY TO
ENSURE THAT IT BE LESS THAT
MARKET IS.
SOMETHING THAT IS A BEING COMBAT
IT THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER OF POLICE ON BEHALF
OF THE UNITED CANNABIS
BUSINESSES OF ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BOLSTER
ENFORCEMENT.
THERE'S A LACK OF ENFORCEMENT
WHICH HAS LED TO THOUSANDS OF
OPERATE OPERATORS PARTICIPATING
IN THE LEGAL MARKET [inaudible]
FOR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THE LAST.
EXPLORE SOME HAVE A FLOW KANA IN
SILICON VALLEY CAMPUS CLIENTS A
WE'VE SUPPORT PROPOSAL
APPRECIATED TO MIND ARTS OF
FUNDING WE WOULD ALSO
ADDITIONALLY APPROACH PRECIADO
SUPPORT IF THOSE FUNDS WERE IN
ADDITION TO TWENTY SIX MILLION
PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AND THE TEN MILLION WAS
ESSENTIALLY PLACED HIGHER UP IN
THE FOOD CHAIN -- SUCH THAT
THERE BE TWELVE THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FROM FOR SPENT
BY APPRECIATE THE RESTRICT YOUR
FOR ENFORCEMENT IN THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE FOR THE OTHER
REPRESENTS IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY SHOW UP ON A YOU HAVE
BEEN HERE THE PAST.
MISTAKES HAS BEEN HERE HELPING
US CRAFT LEGISLATION WORKING
WITH US.
I THANK YOU SO FOR THE REST OF
YOU.
A. B. THAT'S TO BE ENGAGED --
OBVIOUSLY YOU NEED TO WATCH THE
TAPE FROM LAST WEEK TO SEE WHAT
I'M SOME OF THE ISSUES ARE.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WITHOUT THE
CANNABIS TAX PLAN WITH SPECIFIED
CHANGES AT THAT PLACE OTHER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND WE
APPROPRIATE TEN MILLION FOR THE
ACTUALLY PROGRAM.
AND BUDGET BILLING IT AS
OUTLINED THEIR EMOTION.
ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER.
HI Q..
LACKEY I IS AARON WICKS.
CELEBRITIES THE END OF OUR
MEETING ON THINK MY COLLEAGUES.
FOR I NEED TO VOTE CHANGE.
AN ISSUE ONE FROM NOT VOTING TO
NO.
ISSUE ONE FOR NOT VOTING TO KNOW --
THE ITC.
DO WE NOTED.
MR TRUMP SORRY.
SO ON THE WHAT'S.
IT LIKE TO DO IS VOTE YES ON
EVERYTHING EXCEPT FOR PROBATION
NUMBER.
SIX NO THAT IS ALREADY IN
SUPPORT BUT I LIKE TO JUST HAVE
A TO NUMBER.
I DON'T KNOW NOTHING
[inaudible]
DOING NOTED.
SOMETHING MY COLLEAGUES FOR A
THEIR OF JUST PATIENTS UP.
FOR ACTUALLY PREVIEWED YOU GUYS
WERE GREAT GROUP STAFF WITH
AMAZING STAFF THAT -- DO A GREAT
JOB FOR US FROM -- IS THERE
ANYBODY FINANCE AND ILLEGAL.
HE FEELS CAN I JUST SAY YES
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR THE
INCREDIBLE WORK THIS IS A
COMMITTEE THAT REQUIRES A LOT OF
LOT OF HOURS A LOT OF ENERGY AND
YOU'VE.
PUT IN ALL VICTOR THANK YOU INTO
THE STUFF AND STUFF OUT WITH
THAT WERE DONE.
JOINT [inaudible]
I KNOW.
WHY IS IT TOO LATE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
I WAS.
BUT MEMBERS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
IT WAS ON BOTH